January 6th is remembered as a day where political
violence rattled American democracy as we saw our
nation's leaders like then house Speaker Nancy
Pelosi Sheltering in a safe house making calls
and in a now Infamous moment eating a slim jim
but the need for government Refuge is nothing
new during the peak of the Cold War there was a
secret bunker for the entire U.S Congress Scott
McFarland traveled to the mountain state for
a rare look inside the well-preserved facility
and found something powerful outside as well
hidden in the West Virginia mountains on an 11
000 acre estate The Greenbrier
resort is an imposing white structure
but inside is draped in bright colors and
classical pieces a design originally from the
1940s that's intentionally bold there's no beige
there's no beige around here you know retired
Greenbrier historian Dr Robert Conti says it
was an escape for the most powerful how many U.S
presidents have been here 28 is a current count as
far back as Martin Van Buren James Monroe was here
but he was only secretary of state at that point
and for 30 years The Greenbrier also had a secret
Congress ordered construction of a backup U.S
Capitol that would double as a nuclear fallout
shelter below the resort we kind of forget how
intense the Cold War was the United States and the
Soviet Union and people at the time particularly
military people weren't thinking if this is going
to be used they were thinking when it's going to
be used they would convene right here right it
wasn't just Hunker in the bunker they were going
to continue to function as the legislative branch
completed in early 1962 it includes an auditorium
as the house chamber and bunk beds for all 535
members of congress the people who operated the
bunker had a mantra they repeated over and over
we were maintain this at a constant state of
operational Readiness at a moment's notice
at a moment's notice with an infirmary police
equipment and a kitchen and dining room these
are the original floors yeah these original
floors and it was actually designed this
way to be sort of annoying and irritating all
these little little black and white floorings
that didn't want people to sit around here they
had to do multiple sittings so eat and get out
was kind of their philosophy then Congressional
leaders Lyndon Johnson and Sam Rayburn approved
the plan considering the location strategic if war
broke out they assumed the Washington DC would be
a primary target why didn't they put the set of
military facility it would have been a lot easier
but Sam Rayburn and Lyndon Johnson they wanted to
maintain the independence of the legislative they
weren't going to put their facility on a military
base that reports to the Executive Branch the
construction work was unknown even to the staff
of the resort how are you going to build 112
000 square foot underground bunker without people
noticing well you build an addition to the green
bar on top of it and you say oh we're just adding
to the green brown we're just expanding the green
bar and they were it operated until 1992 when
it was Declassified but the hotel held prior
rolls the war isn't over yet during World War
II the government transformed The Greenbrier
into an Army hospital and it also served as an
internment camp for diplomats from enemy Nations
for Generations the bunker and the resort above
it were this refuge in waiting a theoretical safe
place until the day it was no longer theoretical
the death toll from flooding in West Virginia is
at least 20. a thousand year flood ripped apart
White Sulfur Springs in 2016 submerging the homes
of many of the greenbriar's employees including
the home of Mackenzie Moya who worked in the
Greenbrier as a teenager alongside her mother Moya
was pregnant when she lost her home seems like it
just happened yesterday but then sometimes it it
still seems unbelievable that it happened it was
just an unimaginable scene to see the town that
I had grown up in just an absolute ruin buildings
were flattened there were cars everywhere trees
down houses missing my dad calling me I can't see
your house anymore I'm not sure where your mom
is he was on a roof at my neighbor's house your
house was lifted off the ground it came up off the
foundation and floated about a football field away
into my neighbor's house behind me moya's Mom
managed to survive the torrent the two men that
were with her about six hours held her with a rope
around her in the tree and she wasn't physically
able to get completely into the tree so some of
her body was still in the flood waters as she was
clinging to the tree for her life so the creek
water comes all the way up to the bridge it was
remarkable there was water from The High Ground
over here as far as you can see architect and
local business owner Tom Crabtree recalls the
devastation how many people were lost in this
community there were 13 perished the greenbrier's
grounds were wrecked but its Hotel remained intact
Greenbrier opened their doors to anybody that was
displaced by the flood and and it was a remarkable
thing the rebuilding of White Sulfur Springs
continues but has already made the city stronger
initially people invested in this town by donating
funds for volunteers to build homes all of the
construction materials were purchased locally
all of the restaurants were serving food to
hundreds of volunteers momentum continued and Main
Street White Sulfur Springs today has no vacant
storefronts has no vacant space encouraging
its people to stay what kept me here was the
opportunity to raise my daughter in the same
place that I was raised in and played Sports
in and loved living you hear about the beauty in
West Virginia of like the landscape but the sense
of community that it brought really shows you the
people in this area saving a place that's long
been America's Safe House for CBS Saturday morning
Scott McFarland White Sulfur Springs West Virginia
Safe House indeed pretty fascinating I
like the bunk beds I know the arguments
that Congress has over who's going to take
one off can we imagine that the discussion
over who's who's taking which bunk bed
who's on top the bottom I didn't even
think about that Jeff that's an excellent
point brilliant Point naturally you make it
just leave it right there